this is a spike protein it's what gives
the coronavirus its unmistakable look
and scientists think it may be the key
to why new variants of the virus are
becoming more
transmissible a new study by the cdc is
raising the alarm on the coronavirus
variant spreading across the country the
fast spreading covid19 variant first
found in the uk
is now evolving in a way that could make
existing vaccines
less effective new research shows that
the more transmissible variant from the
uk
called b117 will likely become the most
common version of the virus in the u.s
the big concern is that with more
transmissible variant you have more
cases and you have more chance for super
spreading events and epidemic surges
which overwhelm our health care systems
here's the science behind why these new
variants are spreading
faster and what this could mean for
vaccines
like other viruses when the coronavirus
replicates
small genetic mistakes or mutations can
occur
you can be almost certain that as long
as there's a lot
of virus circulating in the community
there will be the evolution of mutants
because that's what viruses do many of
those do nothing
some of those actually confer a survival
benefit
for the virus to transmit more
effectively for instance
abroad quran is a global health
physician who has been studying the
coronavirus pandemic
and so as it does that it has a better
chance of spreading to new hosts and
continuing to replicate in those hosts
koran says this is likely what is
happening with a new more transmissible
variants
appearing around the world recent
research has shown that a number of
these new versions of the virus have
mutations
that affect the spike protein take a
look at this model of the coronavirus
you can see each spike protein is made
up of three identical parts
known as protomers these protomers have
the ability to change their position
from closed to open affecting how easily
they can bind to and
infect human cells you can visualize it
like a flower
so you've got petals on the outside the
really obvious thing that you see
there are three of them the three of
them have to bind to the receptors
jeremy lubin is a virologist who studies
the coronavirus
he explains that when the protempers are
down infection is more difficult
but when these parts are up and open
it's much easier
in the first version of the coronavirus
that originated in china in 2019
these protomers usually had a closed
shape
which may have made it less
transmissible than some more recent
versions of the virus
this is another view of the spike
protein that helps to show
where these mutations occur in the
winter of 2020
one mutation known as d614g
emerged it appears in this region of the
spike protein
this mutation made it more likely for
the spike to have an open
shape increasing the viruses ability to
infect human cells
soon after the mutation emerged variants
that had it took over
so by june pretty much all the viruses
around the planet
had this change this mutation our belief
is that
it supplanted the original virus because
it was more transmissible lubin thinks
this is what is happening with some of
the new variants that are emerging
around the world as well
in the united kingdom that variant
really expanded very rapidly it was
first seen in september and now it's
it's the dominant version of the virus
circulating
in the united kingdom does indeed appear
as if the same thing happened
in south africa another element that
affects the spike protein
is antibodies these are proteins that
defend the body
against the coronavirus by blocking the
ability of the spike protein
to attach to cells which prevents the
virus from infecting
antibodies are produced by the immune
system in response to infection
or vaccines and so far the new
coronavirus variant
scientists are worried about all have
mutations that affect the spike protein
here are some that scientists are
focusing on the first
is called n501y which was first detected
in the variants from the uk
and south africa in the second half of
2020
this mutation is located in a region of
the spike protein
known as the receptor binding domain or
the rbd
this is the main location where the
virus attaches to human cells and
infects them the n501y mutation
seems to be helping the virus bind which
could help explain
the higher transmissibility the second
mutation
that scientists are focusing on is
called e484k
it's found in variants from south africa
and brazil
and reduces the ability of certain
antibodies to bind to the rbd
which helps the viruses chances of
infecting cells what the antibody
recognizes
is a shape if you're playing with blocks
and you have a
you have triangles and and circles and
you have to fit them
into the appropriate holes
you can't fit a circle into a triangular
hole
um it's analogous to that if the virus
then changes so that it's no longer a
triangular hole but it's a circular hole
then the antibody will no longer fit
scientists have also found
that some of the new coronavirus
variants have parts missing
in a region that comes off the side of
the spike protein
this is known as the n-terminal domain
some of those mutations
removing surfaces of the protein that
other antibodies bind to if the virus
mutates that surface
or deletes it those antibodies are no
longer
going to work to block the virus
scientists say this may help explain
why current vaccines may be becoming
less effective
against some new variants this is why
experts are urging caution
variants are going to continue emerging
and we need a public health strategy
that addresses it we have to focus on
getting better ventilation
we have to get people better personal
protection better higher grade mass
that can filter better and we have to
test we have to trace we have to isolate
the
fundamentals of epidemic control and
koran says that while vaccines
should still be effective in preventing
severe illness
a booster variant shot may be needed
later in the year
they work extremely well right now right
with moderna
and pfizer 95 vaccine efficacy they will
start to work less well against some
variants
into the future but that is to be
expected
and that is why vaccines will be a major
part of
covet control for the foreseeable future
experts continue to emphasize the
importance of getting vaccinated
along with other strategies to keep
transmission low
and stop the spread